Sex in the City - good title okay so
right off the bat I'll admit I haven't
seen Sex in the City
anything ever I might have seen bits of
the movie in passing I might have seen
like an episode of the show years ago
but ultimately I'm not really versed in
the ways of sex in the city because I'm
a straight guy and we have Entourage
okay so Sex in the City is an adult
female culture phenomenon not a tween
female culture phenomenon which is just
coming sooner than we want but it's safe
to say that sex in the city is like a
religion to women at least the women I
know they they love this [ __ ] but in a
weird way I can kind of see why like I
said I'm not relieve the demographic for
Sex in the City but I do understand why
women find this appealing but I will
hand it to the writers of Sex in the
City on a couple aspects text in the
city is not torture it's not like
Twilight where I'm sitting there
watching the movie the whole time I'm
just like I mean the writing's clever it
has some pretty witty dialogue and it's
clearly meant to be appealing for adults
not tweens I mean I can see the appeal
for women to go to this movie and watch
these women on screen who embody
everything that they want to be who live
the lives they want to live I mean like
I said we guys we do the same [ __ ] with
Entourage so I'm not really gonna bash
anyone for watching movie for that
prospect so in Sex in the City - Terry
Bradshaw and her friends or Carrie
Bradshaw and her friends yeah different
person have all settled down in some
aspect of family life but now they just
need some straight-up vacay together so
they go to Abu Dhabi is that where
Garfield always wanted to send nermal so
they'll get away and they live 9 star
lives which will make you either happy
or make you want to kill yourself but to
be honest the prospect of this movie has
been done a million times before you
know the whole grass is always greener
on the other side I appreciate what you
have things I mean it's pretty much like
gonna sell in our new lives but I miss
the way things were but so just get away
yeah we're away in men and shoes be
thankful for what you have I am thankful
for what I have my life is perfect
then yeah you read that right this movie
is 2 hours and 20 minutes long it's long
but it also did address what I think are
legit is in relationships like even
after marriage people still want their
independent space apparently a lot of
people don't know that they think once
the ring gets on any and all need and
want for independence has just washed
away in reality it's just not the case
I'm glad this movie addressed that and
guys the good part is if your woman
loves Sex in the City then she should
also realize
whole theme of the movie is BFFs for
life and so she should realize that
she'll have the most fun if she leaves
you at home and takes her friends to go
watch this movie so you have dodged a
bullet for now until the real bullet
hits
so when short Sex in the City - does
have some witty dialogue in some funny
moments especially if you're a woman but
the long ass runtime and the tired and
overuse theme make it but if you're a
woman and a fan of sex in the city
you're gonna have a good time for two
and a half hours and you'll actually get
all the jokes but guys you might want to
stay home for this one because what guy
would want to watch Sex in the City -
this weekend it'll just be a movie
theater that's filled with women who
were all there with their women friends
who all got juiced on wine before they
came to the movie theater who are all
now buzzed and watching a movie that's
made to make them feel young and
carefree again maybe I will go to the
movie theater this weekend saying it
sounds smart if anyone has an argument
against it I would love to hear it
something tells me it won't be as smart
as being a single guy going to watch Sex
in the City this weekend that's right
rollin a theater for ass always classy
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more then click here
to see more
[Music]